اذا يخضع ترامب لتحقيق في 37 تهمه جنائيه
منها ما يتعلق بعرقله العداله ومنها ما
يتعلق باسرار نوويه خطيره اذا يخضع فيها
للتحقيق في 37 تهمه جنائيه منها ما يتعلق
بعرقله العداله ومنها ما يتعلق باسرار
نوويه خطيره شرطه مايامي قالت انها جاهزه
للتعامل مع الحشود الكبيره والاحتجاجات في
جلسه الاستماع لترامب الذي يواجه
الاتهامات القضائيه للمره الثانيه خلال
شهرين لكن هذه المره على مستوى الفيدرالي
فقد اعلنت وزاره العدل الامريكيه الجمعه
توجيعه توجيها 37 اتهام له في قضيه ارشيف
في البيت الابيض لكن لدى ترامب بريق امل
فمن سيتراس المحكمه وتدير متلا وامامها
اليوم هي القاضيه ايلين كانون والتي عينها
ترامب قبل ثلاثه اعوام في المحكمه
الفيدراليه للمنطقه الجنوبيه من فلوريدا
والم عروفه بقرب هذا الحزب الجمهوري
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات